The other type of reasoning is inductive reasoning, and this is when we draw
general conclusions from specific information. Now this is different than
deductive reasoning where we can make certain and necessary correct
conclusions. With inductive reasoning, we can only rely on highly likely
outcomes. For example, you may say that all cats you've known have been
friendly; therefore, all cats are friendly. And that may be the case for your
experiences. But for me, I've known some friendly cats, but I was also attacked
by a pack of feral cats when I was a little girl. Therefore, your inductive
reasoning is different than my inductive reasoning, and we can't be sure that
we've come to the correct conclusion. But let's go to Greg now and he's going
to discuss inductive reasoning in a little more detail.